we'll start shortly okay give me a
little refresh give me a refresh
okay we're good
the chat's just like where
oh okay
producer of The Legend of Zelda series
hello
good to see you sir
why does he always look so classy until
the launch of The Legend of Zelda tears
of the Kingdom
in this vast world that seamlessly
connects the surface and sky
you'll be able to enjoy using your
imagination to the fullest while
exploring it's not long until you can
experience this unfamiliar Hyrule
I'm also very excited to see how you'll
explore this world
as am I sir as are all the people
excited about Ultra hand final trailer
before the game's launch
okay
all right then let's take a look
please enjoy
sorry sorry I'll shut up as much as I
can
yellow clouds
wow everything is very golden up here
isn't it
oh
oh we got a new oh we got a new flute
going on there's a choo choo up there
I wonder who's gonna win that encounter
yes more on the Golems
[Music]
damn where is he jumping from
that are some delicious music
[Music]
and the breath of the Wild theme
hey okay
I knew it I knew Hiro was just gonna be
reimagined from like the ground up I
freaking knew it
what was he running towards
the sky is coming down the ground is
coming up
whoa oh
[Music]
I knew it I freaking knew it I knew it
did you see her start to Glow
he missed her
that's cool
[Music]
Zelda
oh my God on your night and that
legendary sword he carries play our last
line of defense will be link
[Music]
excuse me who link
excuse me who
[Music]
made a wagon
he made a rocket
what is is that Ultra jump
[Music]
machine
oh my God
I know why I am here
something only I can do
those bastards are back
and the birth of his new world
oh there he is it's the
it's the oh my God
[Music]
but you are not alone
siding reveal
look at him go such a stud final hope
oh my God I cannot
I don't even know what where to begin I
don't even know where to begin wait
let's make sure there's nothing else let
us make doubly sure
well apparently just chilling up there
in the in the sky islands as well
skyrill as I like to call it there was
so much Zelda in this trailer
as opposed to all the other trailers
that just removed her from the situation
that I I don't
like I said I don't even know where to
begin with this stuff guys oh my God
okay well let's begin by uh just talking
about it for a little bit
um
okay first off first off how we feeling
how we freaking feeling about that
did you see his face
where is it
look at my boy my guy my man look at it
would you just look at it
what's going on with this
oh my God and then he's got no I know I
know that he's got some long hair back
there I saw it I saw the locks back here
but oh my God what a perfect design so
recognizable but yet still new and it's
the yes it is the nose it's all the nose
and I am so freaking glad that he
rehydrated I cannot begin to stress to
you
how glad I am that he is actually
getting a face and some musculature and
we can all get thirsty over him anyway
uh let's let's just go ahead and start
talking about this why don't we
God what did we even just see
all right so first things first
um first things first
[Music]
all right guys so first things first
everybody I just wanted I just want to
send a blanket message out there for all
these people everybody who said if
you've ever out of the words this is
going to come off a little hostile I'm
sorry if you ever ever uttered the words
it's just DLC I I don't want you to hurt
yourself I just want you to give
yourself a little just a little that on
the cheek okay just be a little
disappointed in yourself and go just
like that okay okay don't hurt yourself
but that this is
they reworked all of Hyrule from the
ground up there's there's all sorts of
stuff spawning from underneath the
ground which we will get to here in just
a sec
obviously the the biggest thing about
this trailer is all the character
reveals that it had we'll get to that as
well but this is so so much more than
DLC guys okay now check this out
now check this out
so in so obviously
obviously this is hateno
and uh
everybody's worshiping mushrooms now I
guess there's obviously we can only
speculate we can only speculate but how
weird is it to see him come back to
hateeno
and just see a bunch of mushrooms
everywhere you know what I mean look at
this so look at what happened to the
fashion shop over here now it's got like
a like a mushroom dress this person here
is wearing a mushroom we've got these
um
umbrella shrooms
we've got
what what's up with that huh
anybody have a mushroom theory for me
yes I know I know the leaks I know but
listen listen we're not talking about
the leaks okay
we're not talking about the leaks yes if
you've seen the leaks then some things
in this Frame right here excuse me will
be somewhat familiar okay they're all on
shrooms now you're right yeah it's from
the Mario movie which by the way
loved absolutely loved
okay and then this this actually makes
me quite excited because people are
starting to move back to Hyrule Castle
town you know what I mean
and that's just something that we never
got to see in breath of the wild you
know because everything in breath of the
wild was so broken and desolate and in
tears of the Kingdom they're going to be
rebuilding
and I think that's just one of the most
exciting things to me
demise no I don't I don't know I don't
think it's demise I'm just gonna go
ahead and throw that out there well
maybe the the
obviously demise is connected to
everything anyway but if you're talking
about the face that we saw that would be
Ganondorf
and in our next shot we've got this is
this is also is this not hatteno
no that's kakariko
is this kakariko
that's kakariko right that that was
kakariko right I'm sorry it guys you you
think that I play breath of the wild
daily but I really don't it's been a
while
I talk about the game daily but it's
been a while I'm pretty sure this is kak
Rico yes
yes it is what
there's a big zonai donut a Zone nut if
you will sitting above kakariko and
we've got to talk about it what flavor
is it Etc
but no this this I can only assume that
this is fallen from the sky you know and
in fact there's a whole bunch of stuff
everywhere that's falling from the sky
aonuma said in the previous
um gameplay reveal thing that if we were
to go over all of the changes to Hyrule
it would take way way way too long
so
as you can see
caught you off guard Jazzy The Zone nut
I know right
and then of course we've got these
little uh
whatever they're gonna be literally
nobody knows for sure yet but my thought
personally since there are so many of
them scattered around as either one
they're going to be some sort of
connection
to Sky rule two they're gonna kind of be
the new take on shrines or three they're
gonna be kind of a mix of both so maybe
you'll go in there you'll have to
complete some puzzle and then it will
unlock
kind of that it it has the seal
okay a very similar kind of seal that
was holding Ganondorf down
and that's just a fact
so if you if you take that logic right
and I know there have been videos made
of this this is just me just speculating
just right now you're hearing it live
um if you take that logic then something
sealed in there so it could be a warp it
could be you know to to Sky rule it
could be it could be who knows who knows
one thing that uh
you guys have all probably noticed is
that links upgrades and stuff have all
been reset in this game he goes back to
three hearts he goes back to the
original stamina wheel so he's gonna
have to have some sort of completion
thing
you know Shrine type thing uh so that he
can collect whatever and upgrade himself
again
so I'm thinking that this might just be
exactly that I don't know
crispy said says maybe what sealed is a
pyramid-shaped bum
listen if we got pyramid-shaped bombs
game of the year
now what is this
we're zooming we're zooming real quick
you know how Nintendo likes their with
their quick zooms you know what I mean
and by the way I will be analyzing this
in a video like in a proper video so I'm
just getting my preliminary ideas right
now and then I'm gonna
get a video up for you guys
[Music]
sorry I can't let it play I have to look
at the frames this is how YouTubers
Watch trailers
yeah that yeah that that's what I was
talking about that you see it you see
what I'm talking about the freaking
tornado now I know I know that my good
buddy monster maze has done a theory
video on this and uh
damn it it's been like a year or two and
I do not remember what he was saying
about it but
to me guys this only means one thing
dungeons you know you know look look
it's the perfect combination is it not
of the world that they've built with
breath of the wild that's very just
go anywhere do anything right and then
linear like Dungeons that you need to go
and complete see the way that you
combined both of those uh Concepts is by
having your open world but then having
certain sections in that world be kind
of locked away you know almost linear
yes almost linear but not quite because
you you have the option to go there
whenever you want
to me that's some sort of freaking wind
Temple okay
that's what I'm that's that's what I'm
thinking that's what I'm thinking
Jazzy says isn't that Tower above Hebron
Mountain
by Dave I think you're right I think I
see that little bite mark in that
mountain over there so I do believe that
is he run if that's the one in the
Northwest sorry
geography brains sometimes you know what
I mean sometimes but uh yeah I think
you're right I think you're right
what if it's a dragons as a random
person
is this where the Deku Tree was I don't
think so I think that's over there by
Hebron and the DECA trees over there
kind of Eastward I think
and then of course we can see some sky
islands and this these sky islands are
very interesting because this just looks
like it's a it was a structure and then
just kind of got stretched out as it
went Skyward or stretched out as it went
groundward if you will
oh okay this clearly in the Gerudo
desert and we've got something being
Unearthed and I think it's the same
thing that jumped up here at the end
this this monster or something which was
just insane to look at
see
and see we can see some new uh little
spiral Shrine things in the desert as
well so they're popping up all over the
place
yeah do you see this oh this was not the
okay this my bad hold up
NYX what I just said in the past like
two minutes this is a structure coming
up out of the ground not the monster my
bad my bad Next Step this is a structure
coming out of the ground and if there is
a structure
rising out of the Gerudo desert
friends Romans countrymen lend me your
logic what else could it be but the
arbiter's grounds or the spirit Temple
all right unless they're just gonna try
to pull a completely new structure out
of their ass
which they could
I suppose
this has got to be the arbiter's grounds
especially because that area was already
there in breath of the wild and there
was weirdly right nothing there it's
like you go to the Arbiters grounds area
and you just do the freaking John
Travolta meme you know you're like
ain't nothing here
so it would make sense if it finally
was something you know what I mean
all right so this was Rising this was
rising and I don't think there's much
that we can tell from it the listen the
only reason why I would say maybe it's
not arbiter's grounds is because of just
how Zona it looks you know what I mean
look at it it's clearly got zonai
architecture going on it's got the whole
like you know the the kind of veed out
structure you know it's got the swirls
the the kind of square-ish swirls it's
got the little beads you know clearly
this is a Zone ice structure that is
coming out of the ground
so that is unfortunately some decently
big evidence against it being arbitrus
grounds because Arbiters grounds for
those that know or don't know or forgot
whatever arbiter's grounds uh was
constructed by
actually we don't know that's actually a
theory however clearly it was not the
Zona it was highly in construction
Gerudo Construction
all sorts of stuff
so I'm not sure about that and then of
course we've got the infamous Falling
Sky rule pieces all over Hyrule
oh yeah it's wonderful I wonder how many
innocent women and children these things
hit on the head
how terrible
and as you can see it is a phenomenon
that happened upon whatever Ganondorf is
doing here whatever he did
this all right
oh this is one of my favorite shots
because like when you see it you don't
really know what you're looking at yet
but then you see the flowing hair and
you're like
yeah you know you just start screaming
look it's groose it's groose guys
or descendant who knows so I'm assuming
because see you see where he's standing
you see where he's standing he's in he's
in the castle so he's raised the castle
and he's standing out on one of the
balconies and he's looking at the blood
moon which is bigger than ever it's
bigger
it's better ladies and gentlemen it's
too much for Mr Incredible you know what
I mean and he's just basking in its glow
and the blood moon is what rehydrates
him look at that I'm pretty sure we can
literally see
his arm
no no that's not his arm
but I was gonna say I I thought we could
I thought that was like his arm like you
know what I mean like get informed right
in front of our faces but that's not
what that is that's like his robe so
he's gonna have some some cool clothing
look at him making a little claw hand
what a powerful head of
thank you
and then I do like that they they just
expanded on this it I will say what is
that killing killing Mystic is that not
demise no that is not demise
that is not device
no no it's not demise I I don't I don't
I don't think so I think it's Ganondorf
it's got to be Ganondorf it's the same
being that had the Gerudo symbols all
over him demise has no reason to wear
Gerudo symbol symbolism all right
uh that's a Ganondorf thing plus the
face later on looks a hell of a lot like
Twilight Princess Ganondorf Ocarina of
Time Ganondorf you know and a hell of a
lot less like demise so I'm just going
to throw that out there
I do like that they showed this scene
[Music]
uh how oh and then look at this look at
that look at that
look at that look at that
she's getting warped
she's literally getting warped do you
guys remember what this is look look
I'll prove it to you I will prove it to
you let's just look up some breath of
the wild ending fight right doesn't
matter who
check this out
after you beat Calamity Ganon
look
see it
you see what I'm talking about right
look
uh-huh and
same damn thing she's getting warped
you love how nerdy I'm getting when I'm
seeing all this that's just that's just
who I am all right that's just my
default state of being so she is getting
warped somewhere so she's not gonna go
you know what I mean she's not gonna get
any fall damage here I don't think now
the question is is she doing the warping
because she's supposed to be out of
power
or is it one of these other people that
we're seeing in the trailer now let's
get to them
sorry guys I also have the sniffles whoa
I'm sorry when the trailer was going on
I didn't even realize what was happening
here look at all these sinkholes
in the Gerudo desert
it's just DLC guys it's just DLC it's
just DLC it's not a sequel It's just DLC
[Music]
they're just and they're just not going
to expound on this of course now we
don't get a shot I don't believe of any
of that structure that rose up
so this is just another area in the
Gerudo desert
hey plot twist what if this is the
arbiter's grounds huh because see these
pillars
these pillars are not zonai pillars
all right
damn you just noticed that what these
little sinkholes yeah I'm sorry I was
concerned about uh my girl Zelda
okay now this is another interesting
shot because if you
look also uh I guess we will have some
of the same uh armor sets from uh breath
of the wild and same armor pieces and
stuff maybe it is DLC no I'm just
kidding but um if you look like there's
falling lava and still to this day we
have not seen anything else in tears of
the Kingdom that would indicate any
other area that should have lava
other than Death Mountain
okay
he's inside Death Mountain so you do you
know what that means structures inside
Death Mountain dungeons fire dungeons
Sky dungeons dungeons are happening okay
and I couldn't be more excited okay I'm
gonna quiet down
and I mean as far as the structure is
concerned I mean there's there's a lot
going on here but there's also not that
much going on here so I just there's
there's no way to tell I mean it looks
like there's like Runners all over the
place like decorative stuff
so I don't freaking know it's one of
those zonite things you know one of
those zonite things
crispy said says if I know anything
about sand from Minecraft it falls down
one of those
underneath
agreed
okay and then this is freaking crazy
because it's not the only one here it's
multiple the zonai
are making a freaking Army you see this
in in
I don't even
I don't even know what that means I I
don't I can't even begin to
conceptualize what that means
there's gonna be an army oh
geez Louise so we're we're
in what role does link play into this
and is that why he has the freaking
outfit is that just the Army outfit is
that what that is is he wearing the
freaking Garb of the zonai people
ah
you think this is inside the tornado it
could be it could be it's definitely at
least outside it because that's the
tornado right there
but these look at look at these warships
guys
and they fly and there's lightning and
it's sweet and it's miraculous and look
at link he looks dope as hell
okay now this there he has his Ultra
jump going again the ultra drum is
something that I I'm I'm super curious
about but I know that there's no way we
can expand on it at all but I mean like
I don't know if that's gonna be like a
low gravity type thing going on or what
but Link's got like a space jump you'll
see it more here in just a second
so you there's going to be these
floating freaking orbs of water how
delicious and amazing this is insane
simply
and definitely going to challenge my
uh hand-eye coordination
and again I can't help but assume that
this is going to be part of like a
dungeon okay
space cadet says give it to me straight
doc you think you could win game of the
year do you think it could go in Game of
the Year because I sure as hell think it
could win game of the year
I think it's probably a given at this
point
even out of the Mario movie is going to
win game of the year okay
and did you see did you see his little
flight suit
do you see it I'm gonna pause
do you see it
look at his flight suit
Mmm delicious
delicious I can only assume that that
means that he's going to be able to hold
his place in air
longer and have greater maneuverability
side to side like a flight suit or a
Glide suit does it look like it's Rito
made it does look like it's Rito made it
looks like wings but then again with the
Zone eye being as mysterious as they are
I'm sure they knew what wings were as
well so who the hell knows at this point
it's not green so you know it does kind
of look like Dorito colors so it's it's
it could be Rita made
okay and then here's just again
structures that he is
defeat what is this is a giant
gumball machine
it's a giant gumball machine that he's
gonna have to go up and take a ball out
of
and use it to complete whatever
structure this is I swear I swears
I wonder how the gumballs taste now this
looks exactly like the Labyrinth
obviously which means that it is zonai
in structure hell this could be the
thing that rose up in uh the desert we
don't know
and then this is just like there okay so
there's all sorts of Wars going on all
right we've got the hylians down here
making an assault look at that look at
this guy look at this guy
this is Biggie cheese personified as a
human you know he's got his freaking
Fedora and his shield and he's just
charging up a goblin
listen grow up to be this guy
shoot for link
but at least hit this guy okay on the
way up
excuse me I'm getting a little excited
uh so yes there is a new spear obviously
there's new Shield new WEP new bow new
spear Link's gonna have a lot of new
trinkets from his adventures up in the
sky that he'll be able to use down in
Hyrule which is amazing
and also all of it wow this is as you
can see the Texan Longhorn modeling
all my Texans out there can I get a
yeehaw
oh
okay
I know things
because of the leaks and I don't want to
talk about the leaks and I'm not going
to talk about the leaks
but I know this individual's name
and it's killing me and I want to say it
but I'm not going to say because I could
literally say it and I'm not gonna say
it I'm just not gonna do it okay I'm
just not gonna do it
but let's just say
there's so much here Seth oh Seth miles
thank you for the Super Chat that's for
you
uh get what did you say hold up I gotta
scroll up
Seth miles Ganon gonna be super hard to
fight looking like that oh I know right
I know right he's got with a nose like
that geez Louise this month can't end
fast enough
I know trust me I know I cannot wait for
this game
okay
so uh yeah this is um and as you can see
behind the individual there are other
individuals standing around the army
okay
is that a foot
excuse me
is that is that a foot
if that's a foot then uh
I don't know about that
small steak oh thank you for the super
check that's for you uh hit this or this
to go frame by frame
oh my God
I I never knew that
I I actually never knew that
I never knew you could do that
my whole career
it's it's just been pressing play and
pause
the whole time hey the drunk one okay
calm down over there
I was trying it was like uh freaking it
looked like two big toes you know like
some beastial looking thing I was just
wondering okay there's nothing going on
here well um I would go frame by frame
but we've still got quite a bit to cover
uh so I'm just gonna do like this
I'm not sure why that was an important
thing for us to see but here let's go
again
also I just want to point out how pissed
this individual looks just want to point
it out
Link's just turning around for some
reason okay now look at this look at
this so we've got we got
we got a crotch that right there ladies
and gents that's a Bonafide crotch all
right and you know what a crotch means a
crotch means that we got other stuff
connected to it all right
we got legs we got a torso we got a head
and from the Torso we've got arms so as
you can see this is some sort of
humanoid thing okay
it's a big ass robot and for some reason
I'm pretty sure we're gonna be fighting
it which is okay I'm totally cool with
that
[Music]
um
and then we've got link looking real
concerned wow he's showing more
expression here than he ever did in the
base game oof
uh I see he does not have the master
sword equipped so he only does that
sometimes
what is it link
what are you feeling what is it boy okay
now look at this look at this this was
super interesting and I noticed this but
I didn't say anything about it he's
standing in the throne room
and it's sparkling
and I can't help but feel like it's kind
of sparkling in the same way
you know in that way
what does it mean
what does it mean does it mean the whole
thing's about to get Warped or something
or is it just Holy Ground
it's weird okay it's weird especially
since canonically this floor excuse me
this floor is all new okay this is all
like 100 new because in breath of the
wild this was broke as hell
Lincoln Ganon just busted through the
ground
so
I don't know guys I don't freaking know
maybe that's maybe the Sparkles is is
I hate to say it I hate to say it maybe
it's warping in time
I hate to say it okay and the reason why
I hate to say it is because everybody
says it and it gets a little old hearing
it but like that would also explain why
it looks so freaking good you know what
I mean
even though there hasn't been a king
here but that isn't necessary because
like Zelda returned to rule her kingdom
so I mean she could have absolutely had
the throne room rebuilt so you know that
that's literally just that's neither
here nor there
could be a flashback that's true we
could just be doing more flashbacks
please no time travel yeah I know a lot
of people are sick of time travel I know
and then the trailer shifts to showing a
whole bunch of Zelda and I can't get
enough of this in the first place do you
see how playable she looks
my Zoe you're looking mighty playable
over there
Zelda
we rely on your night and that legendary
sword he carries see that the first
first instinct is like oh is that her
her daughter her dad her father
our last line of defense will be link
and see he is joining the military so
this is that individual whose name I
cannot
say
I really want to but anyway this is that
individual
talking to her and you can see that
because he's going to put his hand on
her here in just a second and you can
see uh him uh but clearly link is
joining the resistance Le resistance
okay
[Music]
yeah right there this is the same
individual okay
oh my God and we're seeing this Crest
right here and as you can see it looks
beautiful potentially Gerudo maybe not
you know we're just getting We're not
gonna talk about this right now wait for
my wait for my analysis video also look
at look at her new costume she's rocking
she looks great you look great Zelda
[Music]
see that's that's the new individual
right there
and she says link like she doesn't
remember
and that's a little telling to be honest
with you
so that either implies I mean I'm not
going to fully speculate right the
second but that either implies
a big passage of time
actually that's the only thing that
implies
or Zelda in some sort of like new body
with new memories it happened to link in
the first game it's happening to Zelda
in this game right
maybe she has to regain her Memories by
finding the tears
link just looking cool as hell that's
all this shot is just link looking cool
as hell
oh my God I didn't notice that bro
[Music]
okay now we're gonna go frame by frame
look
Zoom
it's a sword shield this concept has
never been thought of before in the
history of humanity
for for thousands and thousands of years
swords and shields have always been two
different things
and now they're the same damn thing
it link is into that's it that's it
goodbye Ganondorf goodbye it's a shield
sword what the hell can you do against a
shield sword imma cut you
imma block you ain't nothing you can do
about it
look at how angry he looks
he's so mad
see this this this guy right here just
made fun of his sword shield and
this is this is like a school bullying
playground scene right here but he's
about to hand it to them but no like
this uh
it's so freaking cool and also if you'll
notice
he's holding this weapon differently
okay than any of the other weapons that
he held in breath of the wild he's
holding it like this
which means that there are new
animations for weapons which potentially
means there are there are new classes of
weapons
oh my gosh and you can even counter with
it it's amazing
and break the hell out of everything
okay let's go back to playing
so that that was that was interesting
what we were seeing inside right there
[Music]
I can only assume that's another dungeon
I can only assume that is another
dungeon in there
some sort of cool ass dungeon yo what is
going on here
we got Amethyst from Steven Universe
whoa okay hello
hi
who are you
okay
I really thought that this was some sort
of being that was curled up in a ball
but then when it
it is it is
look we've got I didn't notice them
sitting there you see these gorons just
chilling there sitting there those could
even be Goron kids I can't tell because
these trailers are never in very high
resolution
but look at that
there's Goron kids just chilling just
eating popcorn Rock Corn Pop Rocks
eating some pop rocks
and just watching this fight so this is
some sort of trial thing so that makes
me think that that
I mean it's speckled so I don't think
this is a Goron
but this this is some sort of thing to
be spectated which is interesting to me
yeah maybe it's giant Samus maybe she
just she just got tired of exploring
space and decided you know what let me
go kick a little blonde kid's ass okay
so as you can see I'm pretty sure that
that is
one of cass's kids question mark
I think so
well either way link is just flying
around with some uh of the retail I
wonder if he still has the Champions
abilities in this game
but either way that's clearly he's like
getting trampolined off of this little
trampoline down here
which I'm assuming is just another of
the many ways to
oh wait okay obvious obvious thing let
me get an obvious thing out of the way
other people are going to explore the
sky islands with you okay
no idea what that even freaking means
that's huge and also these ships are
just flying around in real time
okay
[Music]
and then this is cool as hell look at
that you can harness I don't know why
you would do this maybe maybe this is
the Legend of Zelda charity of the wild
like you can just help people now you
can help rebuild people's houses like
some people were speculating in the
previous gameplay thing and you can help
like transport people to and from
I don't know but it's super freaking
cool one I'm assuming that this is a
side quest you know maybe you find these
people and their wagons broken on the
side of the road they're like oh my God
a fat giant guns of glow
you go fear not I gotta I got an ultra
hand that's what all the ladies call it
and so he's just gonna like fix it for
them and then go on I think I think
that's probably what's gonna happen
there it's gonna be cool
ah
[Music]
and then this this is cool I can't wait
to see more
combat applications of his new powers
and then this this little rocket thing
cool as hell look at this McComb it's
like hey take me with you
and then look okay watch the space jump
watch
[Music]
look it's a space jump why is he space
jumping link did you lose weight you
don't look like it or maybe just being
the higher up you go maybe the gravity
gets lower
I don't know I think that's pretty cool
though
I think that's pretty cool
wait cat Davey says I just went back
over the live to watch and oh wow wow
wow wow
I really can't wait now and it's out
just in time for my birthday too if I
don't see him before then happy freaking
birthday everybody say happy birthday to
Kat
please
if you would be so kind
okay and then here we've got you
remember the the freaking mine cart
racing stuff from Donkey Kong 64. well
now it's in 4k except for it's not in 4k
but you know what I mean
this is cool as hell because link is uh
I don't know he's got some freaking
Minecart combat going on here
this Golem here is not the best shot
you uh
having a little trouble there robot
maybe it's your one eye that's giving
you the problem maybe you need two for
that depth perception I don't I don't
know but this looks cool as hell
and again it looks like it's in that uh
well okay
the stuff that I said earlier about not
seeing anything that implies lava
outside of Death Mountain take that with
a grain of salt because we do have a
bunch of underground areas that we're
probably going to be exploring and who
knows if there's lava flowing under the
ground okay who knows
are you guys saying happy birthday
okay they're saying happy birthday there
you go good good
thank you
okay now this oh my God
oh my God I don't have the words oh my
god look if you have a little arm
can I make like a giant freaking sword
and just bash the hell out of everything
guys it's it's goren Lagan the it's
Zelda the guru and the god anime it's
it's neon Zelda Evangelion it's it's
everything it's everything
it's everything
link get in the damn robot
oh my God
also there's voices going on in in the
soundtrack and and I am I am here for it
as well
okay and then we've got some new armor
for the horses and we've got link just
firing some sort of
that would be a ruby that would be a he
has stuck a ruby
on an arrow it's kind of an expensive
Arrow there link
looks like it gives it fire powers
look at his freaking
face
my what Big Horns you have link I better
be a mask or something
you better you better not be sprouting
things without without informing me
first there link buddy old pal jeez do
you see this
I don't know what's going on there
and then this
okay that was cool as hell so that's
some sort of construct that he can turn
on with the zonai battery and it's got
lasers and stuff that's pretty cool
this is
whoa whoa
that's the scariest thing I've ever seen
link
look out
oh my God
but no look at this okay look at this
look at this this is the same Rito chick
from earlier okay could be cass's
daughter could be not I don't I don't
freaking know I don't think it really
matters at this point the only thing
that does matter is one somebody else is
up with link yeah it's a Reaper
Leviathan literally from subnautica okay
it's about to destroy my uh my seamoth
my poor little seamoth anyway I love
that game by the way uh played too many
hours of that game but anyway what am I
trying to say
oh yeah this Rito chick that's up here
in the sky islands with link is going to
fight bosses with him you know what that
means
dungeons this is a dungeon boss
I I can feel it guys I can feel that
this is a dungeon boss
you cannot tell me that this is just
some wandering
world but I guess it could be a world
boss but I really really want it to be a
dungeon boss I really really want it to
be multiplayer
I don't know
oh it's it's tiva's child it's it's
teva's child sorry sorry it's tiva's
child okay it's been a hot second okay
it's been a hot second
if someone's kid all right
okay there's that same explosion that we
saw in the previous trailer
explosion of malice good stuff okay and
then here we've got Zelda up in the sky
islands
why I am here do you
something only I can do
and also you see on that megatama
that oh oh hold up hold up hold up that
is hold up guys wait
wait
is it
it is
it actually is
wait a second boom
look
look it is
it actually is
it's the same symbol
this is this is his recall ability it's
the same symbol
so clearly clearly okay clearly he's
going to she these magatamas are going
to be
left by Zelda
and then found by link
which again implies time travel
and every time he finds one he's going
to get another ability
telling you telling you you heard it
here first okay but I got I gotta speed
this up because I have to go analyze it
I have to I have to get an analyst and
and now also I'm glitching I have to get
an analysis video up so here let me wrap
this up real quick also Zoro Sapphire
thank you so much for the Super Chat
thank all of you for the super chats you
don't have to do that guys you really
don't thank you so much uh Zelda is
talking to this tall dark
white hair third eye character uh is the
sheikah from the past
could be the Champions could the
Champions be playable as well as Zelda
very good speculations they're very good
speculations the the I have
I have an opinion on who that is because
I know their name
but it was in the leaks so I'm not going
to talk about it so I can't comment on
that uh however could the Champions be
playable as well as Zelda I think the
Champions personally I think the
Champions are dead unless you're talking
about like the champion descendants uh
that would be cool as hell we do see a
side in here in just a sec though
okay hold up hold up hold up and then
this
it's he's gone the whole way with it now
okay he was like this then he was like
this and now he's like this okay he's he
has he's doing some Peck flies is what
he's doing he's squeezing the malice out
of his chest area
and it's flying upward and that is what
we saw in the very very very first
trailer I'm sure and then it leaves the
castle goes through the air travels all
the way upwards and hits
a portal
the very same kind of portal
that
that the dragons go up to in breath of
the wild man the Nintendo was
foreshadowing this all the way back then
guys I believe that this is the action
that makes everything happen
that right there he is shattering the
connection between the two worlds
that is what he is doing
now why he's doing that that's a very
good freaking question I mean he's kind
of Awakening an entire Army that's gonna
come try to kick his ass oh hello there
Mr Lionel hello other lion no
I so hope that these are two like named
three that these are three oh my God
that one looks scary as hell I hope
these are like three named lionels in
the game like the Lionel brothers or
something
oh my God and then this oh ganon's
talking hold up get it or stalking the
king's Revival you witness a king's
Revival and the birth of his new world
and the birth of his new world see this
is this is oh oh my God oh my God oh my
God he looks so good
oh my God just look at him
oh my God and then he's got a giant ass
ponytail
ah
[Music]
that's new don't have much to say about
that hey let's go
okay okay this
is Zelda I I don't see another way
around it it is Zelda
but she's been transformed by the
magatama
question mark
if you guys remember I did a theory with
Celtic
uh on two trailers ago and we talked
about the fact that the Zelda could be
transforming in the game
it sounded crazy but
look
clearly it's not that far-fetched
clearly it's not I am not sure what that
means right this second okay and then
we've got whoa is that Zelda doing that
what what is she she's just firing
Omega beams of light at molduga's
also whoever called it in the last
trailer that that was a her a swarm of
muldugas coming out of uh if you know
around down in the valley where all that
like dust was being kicked up you were
correct look at all the mildugas I don't
know how you had that Insider
information but good freaking job but it
looks like somebody's just fired oh my
God
sorry
read you
excuse me read you
you're freaking stacked what have you
been doing in the past few years so it
looks like riju is going to be a blade
dancer just like herbosa and she's also
stacked as Sin and it looks like her
crown finally fits her and she has
mastered her lightning abilities
and look at how dope she looks
oh look at that shot right there
oh this is the coolest thing I've ever
seen
okay and then there's link and just like
some some hylians this guy's got a
bucket on his head I'm thinking that
since they keep emphasizing like link
end like an army and a group of people
you're gonna be able to like recruit
people
for purposes of what I'm not sure but
you are not alone wait
but you are not alone
[Music]
okay let's go
but you are not alone
[Music]
I don't know who's talking to him there
and that's why I was kind of frozen but
anyway I personally I think that you'll
be able to take the Champions along with
you that's why they're saying you are
not alone you've got these companions
down there you've got siding up here
helping you guys we can take siding
wherever we want to go and he'll help us
fight things how cool is that
so but yeah I don't know who was talking
there I think that might be evolved
Zelda
but I don't know me no that's Zelda
[Music]
I cannot wait for that that is
definitely glioc that is definitely
glioc from the first Zelda game you are
a final hope
in the hell also this is this you see
that right there that's that's Tiba so I
can only assume that somewhere in this
Mighty Run is uh unibo as well why
they're not showing him I don't know
maybe he was maybe he's crying somewhere
because he's too much of a coward maybe
he saw a dog I don't know no wait that's
a daruke
[Music]
now why does she have the master sword
how how does she have the master sword
that goes against the theory of time
travel
my brain I don't know final hope
I don't know y'all I don't know yes it
was amazing and listen I am going to
have to uh end this here in just a
second because I need to go make an
analysis video
and then this is that final shot
come find me you must find me okay all
right guys thank you so much for hanging
out with me thank you so much it this
has been a wonderful wonderful trailer
it's been I cannot believe I've been
streaming for about an hour we've just
been talking about it but now I'm going
to convert this
into an analysis video uh so stay tuned
alright stay tuned love to all thank you
so much I hope you all have a wonderful
day if it press the Subscribe button if
you haven't yet to be notified when it
goes up it's gonna be up here in just a
little bit so I love you guys have a
good day pre-order the game see you next
time this is Bandit signing out peace